tell us a little bit about your journey
from the beginning days as a caddy to
beginning to recognize patterns and some
of the places that you missed along the
way and why misses were so valuable I
know you know you shared with me I think
it was in the early 80s where after
building your company you were so
successful and it looked like you lost
almost everything you got to start over
so I think it'd be really important for
you to understand before we talk about
just the world in the country the
understanding of these patterns and how
they can give you the ability to create
a greater quality of life for yourself
for your family for your company Etc
when I was a kid as you point out I I
caddied I
um delivered newspapers I did a bunch of
jobs when I was a kid at age 12 I bought
my first stock I was cutting the stock
market was hot at the time
um people I carried for were talking
about it uh the first stock I bought was
a stock by the name of Northeast
Airlines the only criteria I had was
that it was selling for less than five
dollars a share I figured I could buy
more shares and if it went up I'd go
more money that was done but the company
was about to be go bankrupt another
company acquired it it tripled in value
and I was hooked on the markets so I
served on the markets
um at the beginning of 12 and that's my
game